Gewaltige Sonnenstürme erschüttern das Erdmagnetfeld
und stellen eine permanente Bedrohung für
uns Menschen dar.
Nicht einmal die ISS ist sicher, wenn das
Erdmagnetfeld erschüttert wird.
Was dazu kommt: Sonnenstürme sind kaum vorherzusagen.
Doch jetzt ist es einem Forschungsteam aus
London gelungen, mit Hilfe von Satelliten
dem Geheimnis der Weltraumbeben auf die Spur
zu kommen.
Auf welche Art und Weise genau das magnetische
Schutzschild der Erde vibriert und ob diese
Erkenntnisse das Leben auf der Erde vor den
fatalen Folgen von Sonnenstürmen schützen
kann, Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier gibt
es täglich faszinierende Sciencevideos, abonniert
den Kanal nur dann und nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Sonneneruptionen sind wirklich ein super spannendes
Phänomen: Dabei wird aus der Sonnenatmosphäre
eine gigantische Wolke aus unvorstellbar heißem
Gas herausgeschleudert.
Die dabei ausgestoßenen Teilchen, Protonen
genannt, können im Weltall Geschwindigkeiten
von mehreren Millionen Stundenkilometern erreichen.
Es formen sich Plasmawolken und dadurch entstehen
magnetische Stürme in unserer Erdatmosphäre.
Dann dringt Röntgenstrahlung in die Ionosphäre
ein und verändert die Eigenschaften so, dass
sich Funkwellen beispielsweise nicht mehr
ausbreiten können.
Vor allem Kurz- und Ultrakurzwellen sind betroffen,
dort findet vor allem der Amateur und Mobilfunk
statt.
Doch auch GPS kann betroffen sein.
Aber auch fatale Folgen für die Stromversorgung
auf der Erde können Sonnenstürme mit sich
bringen, denn riesige Transformatoren werden
dann gegrillt.
Und nicht nur das: Es gibt auch Fachleute,
die zwischen Sonnenausbrüchen und Naturkatastrophen
hier auf der Erde einen Zusammenhang sehen.
Taifune, Erdbeben und auch besonders gigantische
Hurrikans wie “Harvey” und “Irma”
könnten indirekte Folgen von Sonneneruptionen
sein.
Fest steht also: Sonneneruptionen können
auch der Erde und uns Menschen sehr gefährlich
werden.
Selbst, wenn der Abstand zwischen Sonne und
Erde 150 Millionen Kilometer beträgt und
uns auch die Erdatmosphäre einen gewissen
Schutz bietet.
Wenn die ausgestoßenen Partikel die Erde
allerdings ohne Unterlass bombardieren würden,
könnte sicher kein Leben auf unserem Planeten
existieren.
Gut also, dass es das irdische Magnetfeld
gibt, das den aggressiven Sonnenwind um uns
herum lenkt und das Schlimmste verhindert.
Doch klar ist: Das Erdmagnetfeld wird durch
Sonnenstürme erschüttert und verformt.
Die Feldlinien werden auf der sonnenzugewandten
Seite stark zusammengedrückt; auf der abgewandten
Seite dagegen werden die Linien wie ein Schweif
auseinandergezogen.
Das Ganze lässt Kompassnadeln vibrieren und
Polarlichter leuchten.
Schon vor knapp 50 Jahren wurde Fachleuten
klar, dass das Magnetfeld der Erde in Schwingung
versetzt wird, wenn es von einer Teilchenwolke
getroffen wird.
Doch das Krasse daran: Bis heutzutage konnten
solche stehenden Wellen nicht nachgewiesen
werden.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler Martin Archer von
der Queen Mary University in London: “Es
gab Spekulationen, dass diese trommelähnlichen
Vibrationen vielleicht gar nicht entstehen,
da seit ihrer Vorhersage vor 45 Jahren die
Belege fehlten.
Eine andere Möglichkeit war, dass sie einfach
sehr schwer definitiv nachzuweisen sind."
Doch jetzt endlich gelang der entscheidende
Durchbruch und das Team um Archer konnte zeigen,
wie das magnetische Schutzschild der Erde
vibriert: Und zwar wie die wohl größte Trommel
der Welt.
Dieser Erfolg gelang dem britischen Forschungsteam
mit Hilfe der Aufnahmen der fünf NASA-Satelliten
“Themis”.
Diese waren genau zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen
Ort: Sie waren gerade korrekt in Position
gebracht, als ein riesiger Impuls von der
Sonne für ein Spektakel sorgte.
Das irdische Magnetfeld schlug tatsächlich
ähnlich an wie ein Trommel-Klöppel.
In Fachsprache ausgedruckt gelang in diesem
Moment der Nachweis stehender Wellen - eben
wie sie sich auch auf dem Fell einer Trommel
ausbilden.
Dazu Archer: "Wir haben die größte Trommel
der Welt entdeckt.
Diese Trommel ist Dutzende Male größer als
der Planet Erde."
Dieses Erkenntnis überträgt das Forschungsteam
auf andere Planeten.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
vermuten, dass auch die Magnetschilde von
Saturn, Jupiter und Merkur auf dieselbe Art
und Weise schwingen.
Jetzt wollen die Fachleute untersuchen, wie
häufig solche Vibrationen vorkommen und welche
Folgen sie mit sich bringen.
Spannende Fragestellungen, die im besten Fall
so schnell wie möglich beantwortet werden.
Denn bisher sind wir in diesem Themenbereich
eher unwissend unterwegs.
Wir spielen derzeit quasi russisches Roulette
mit der Sonne.
Zwar sehen Teleskope und erdnahe Satelliten
den Ausbruch der Sonne, doch dann muss auch
eingeschätzt werden, wie stark er ausfallen
wird und ob er die Erde überhaupt treffen
wird.
Erst 20 Minuten bevor der Sturm die Erde erreicht,
ist dann auch klar, in welche Richtung sein
Magnetfeld zeigen wird.
Und das ist entscheidend dafür, wie gut er
das irdische Magnetfeld durchdringen wird.
Wichtig wäre es also, die Prozesse auf der
Sonne besser zu verstehen, um sie dann irgendwann
einmal auch exakt vorhersagen zu können.
Der europäische “Solar Orbiter”, der
Anfang 2020 aufbrechen soll, könnte dazu
enorm beitragen.
Und wie gefährlich Sonnenstürme sind erfahrt
ihr hier.
Draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!